There are a few guarantees when it comes to
Deadpool: he'll word-vomit at the most inappropriate
times, he'll slay his enemies in ways once
thought to go against the laws of physics,
and he'll make fun of anything and everything
around him, including the minds behind Marvel's
biggest superhero movie to date.
Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds took the opportunity
to share a message from the red-and-black
anti-hero, who had a few words to say about
people potentially spoiling Deadpool 2.
It only took fans a few seconds to realize
that the note was mostly a parody of the "Thanos
Demands Your Silence" initiative that Avengers:
Infinity War co-directors Joe and Anthony
Russo sparked up to stress the importance
of keeping plot details a secret.
While the Russos addressed their letter to
"the greatest fans in the world," Deadpool
one-upped them by opening with, "To the great-er-est
fans in the whole universe."
The similarities are undeniable, with phrases
from the Russos' letter popping up verbatim
in Deadpool's note, but most of Deadpool's
comments added a ridiculous twist.
For example, one of the "super secrets" his
team has been hiding is the, quote, "secret
blend of 11 herbs and spices in Colonel Sanders'
delicious moustache."
After telling people not to "say a f---ing
word about the fun s--- in the movie," Deadpool
signed off with a hashtag of his own: #WadeWilsonDemandsYourSisterSorryStupidAutocorrectSilence.
And now, the Russo brothers have something
to say.
Replying to Reynolds on Twitter, the directors
fired back with a photo of a prop Infinity
Gauntlet with its middle finger raised, captioned:
"Boom."
"Pump the hate brakes, Thanos."
Reynolds was quick to respond to the flip
of the bird, though this time, he took a higher
road than Deadpool would have, replying, "I
deserve that."
All things considered, it's safe to assume
that the Russos aren't actually angry, and
that the minds behind the Deadpool sequel
don't actually think the Russos' anti-spoiler
attitude is in any way uncool.
How could they?
Infinity War has continued to smash records
at the box office, surpassing the $1 billion
benchmark in record time, and Deadpool 2 first
reactions stamp the sequel film as being bigger,
better, and more brilliant than the original.
Something tells us both parties are too busy
basking in their respective successes to be
truly fired up.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!